Donald Trump is still in the business of throwing
childish tantrums.
This time unleashing the most pathetic attack
so far on Florida Governor Trumps Governor.
Remember, Trump lives in Florida on his own
Governor Ron DeSantis.
Donald Trump, desperate to find new ways to
attack a guy who is defeating Trump in some
polls, despite the fact that Ron DeSantis
hasn't even said, I'm running for this thing.
He's not even a candidate, and he is ahead
of Trump significantly in some polls, including
the most recent Monmouth poll.
This genuinely has the potential to put the
2016 Republican Party to shame in terms of
how humiliating and absurd this primary could
be.
Donald Trump, on the heels of this new Monmouth
poll that has DeSantis beating him by 13,
which we already talked about, has posted
an attack on Ron DeSantis to his platform
Truth social censure, in which he goes after
Ron DeSantis for wearing a blue tie when he
met with Trump in the Oval Office while Trump
was president.
Well, not exactly.
Let's take a look at the post from Truth Social
Trump posting a picture where he is sitting
there with Matt Gaetz and DeSantis.
And who is I forget who the guy is on the
right.
I feel so silly, but I forget who that is.
And Ron DeSantis is wearing a blue tie.
And Donald Trump says in his post.
Who is that in the blue tie being so nice
to the president of the United States while
in the Oval Office.
Now, this is not actually about the tie color.
This is about Trump pointing out Ron DeSantis,
who now says bad things about me, used to
suck up to me.
Now, of course, to all of us who understand
how politics works.
We understand that that's how politics works.
You try to get close to power.
If you're someone like Ron DeSantis, you want
to go to the White House.
Governors love going to the White House.
So of course, you're nice to Trump.
But Trump simply can't help but try to find
anything to attack Santos over.
Recall that last week.
He went after DeSantis for this picture, in
which DeSantis is with some allegedly high
school aged girls who I guess he was teaching
he was the teacher of.
And Trump posted, That's not Ron, is it?
He would never do such a thing referring to
grooming high school girls with alcohol.
Yeah.
Meanwhile, in addition, Trump adding to the
embarrassment by tweeting trash polls in response
to the Monmouth poll, which has Trump down
13 Trump tweeting about a premise poll.
If you haven't heard of premise as a pollster,
they're not even serious enough to be rated
by FiveThirtyEight.
That one has Trump up 30 points.
That seems a little bit difficult to believe.
And Trump also posting a link to a Breitbart
poll, which isn't even a poll.
It's just a favourability poll.
It's not an actual 2024 poll.
It is all completely pathetic.
And this is going to be an insane primary.
Now, I want to oh, I've been wanting to do
this for a little bit.
I want to kind of frame the next 21 months
for you.
If you have read Neil Postman's book Amusing
Ourselves to Death, I know many of you would
think, David, you're not going to quote Technopolis
again, are you know, this is an earlier book
by Neil Postman.
It's called Amusing Ourselves to Death.
Postman wrote this book in the mid-eighties,
I think it was in 85.
And what Postman argued was that if we're
going to do a serious analysis of television
and remember, in the mid-eighties, things
were moving from sort of a print medium dramatically
more towards a visual medium.
Television.
One of the things that Neil Postman talked
about is it's not just about the content of
television, it's about the fact that television
frames all issues as having to be or needing
to be entertaining.
Sesame Street, which is a great program, right?
Sesame Street still implicitly is telling
us learning should be entertaining and it
devalues more difficult forms of learning
that aren't entertaining but require a different
type of thought.
And one of the things that has become true
not only in the era of television, but you
could take Neil Postman's 85 analysis and
make it in 2023 when it comes to social and
online media.
One of the things that has become a reality
is that there is this expectation that the
format of how we get news today, Twitter and
the way TV news is produced and online news
as well.
Okay, I'm part of this.
We now believe politics should also be entertaining.
Debates should be entertaining.
And that's why primary debates and presidential
debates have these one minute answers and
32nd rebuttals, 15 second rebuttals.
It's not to actually learn anything about
the candidates.
In fact, it prevents us from learning about
There are other ways to learn about the candidates.
It tells us politics should be entertaining.
These things should be entertaining.
And so in a sense, I am part of this.
My goal is to work within the formats that
are available to reach as many people as possible
and tell them, Hey, there are better ways
to think through who we're going to vote for
and learn to.
Okay, so what's the point of me telling you
this?
One of the things that we really have to think
about as we go from now into the primaries
and into the general election, is that to
really figure out who we should be voting
for, what policies would be better for the
country, all these different things.
You have to exit the world of where it all
needs to be entertaining.
The unfortunate reality is and we're going
to talk about the strategy later or probably
tomorrow in order to defeat Trump.
And this is the point I'm building to In order
to defeat Trump, Ron DeSantis has to do some
of the things Trump does well.
He has to be entertaining.
He has to attack Trump.
He has to be titillating and salacious.
And Ron DeSantis is going to have to figure
out how.
It is a horrible thing that on the one hand,
we know that all of this is terrible for the
country.
The fact that this is how a Republican primary
is going to be fought, who can come up with
the slickest insults in the entire thing.
I would love to change that.
I can't change that.
And so when we are thinking through how Republicans
are going to choose their nominee, Democrats
to a degree the same thing.
But if Biden runs, they're not really going
to be choosing.
It's going to be Biden.
It's going to come down to who can make their
campaign as entertaining and titillating as
possible, not who can propose the best policy
on health care, not who can lay out the most
sober and sensible foreign policy.
It doesn't make a difference.
What matters is can you compartmentalize it,
make it a snippet and make it as entertaining
as possible.
And that is how politics is done.
And it's a sad and horrible thing.
And we're going to be looking at this election
through that lens.
I'm going to do everything I can to really
try to to to do that, because I think it has
to be done.
All right.
Let's take a quick break.
We have many other things to talk about coming
up in mere moments.